she's been very embedded very publicly
in what I would call radical leftwing
morality for a very long time and suan
niten has this uh particular quote that
probably everyone knows where the the a
lot of the time these people even when
reality is hitting them in the face with
the consequence of their own ideology
they won't admit it well actually uh
Anna is being hit in the face with the
consequences of this morality and it's
going okay I was
wrong
do you think part of that it's not just
that they're afraid of the mob but
there's something so baked into culture
the default of culture that is left and
I know these terms are sort of becoming
increasingly meaningless which is nice
to to an extent but that that's what
they're really afraid of like it's
automatically like oh if you're not for
Equity if you're if you don't think boys
or girls you're automatically framed as
a bad guy now and that people just don't
want to walk from that yeah I think uh
um
the the thing that the left has done
very very effectively is claimed to have
a a monopoly on morality because it
defines morality in quite a narrow way
itself uh it has to be essentially
rationally calculable but actually if
you think about it a lot a lot of what
we actually do that is moral is actually
very sentimental and habitual right we
didn't think about it we just do it
because it's the right thing to do and
so if you are actually taking principles
like freedom and equality well actually
you can destroy the family with those
principles you know you don't owe
anything to your parents and you can't
say that your your father is superior to
you because that's not equality and so
you're you're not bound by being you
didn't choose your parents but you and
so by the the principles of Freedom
equality you can be Unbound from your
own family and like children can have no
responsibility to not only their parents
but their own country and to anything
like it's like God this is actually
quite horrific right and and this is a a
sort of radical form of morality this is
really unusual like nowhere else on
Earth you know even even you know from
very very um sort of loose civilizations
where the society isn't very tightly
knit to you know deeply tribal societies
where literally everyone in the tribe is
sort of like second or third cousins or
something you know ev Everything outside
of leftwing morality is kind of on a
Continuum and has been normal for almost
all human societies to some degree for
all of human for all of time and it's
only since about the French Revolution
incident where this kind of radical
morality asserts itself and says right
this is the left and this is the
absolute liberation of the individual
really ultimately what they want is from
the flesh itself right and this is why
they're stigmatizing the body now oh you
that child needs transition it's like
are you mad you know there's no way a
child can give informed consent to
transition they can't give informed
content get Al
loone can't drink yeah tattoo you know
they can't chop off their own genitals
you Maniacs you know and so this this
radical liberatory morality is something
really quite new and it's you are right
it's not just the identity of the left
it's not just that they're trapped in it
I actually think that they're afraid
that if they kind of accept hang on a
second I bought into all of this
wholesale then what they're saying is I
was being evil actually and that's a
really difficult thing to look yourself
in the mirror and say oh everything I
did was wrong every time I cheered on a
teenage girl who got her breasts removed
and stitched up I was ruining someone's
life actually and so it's easier to say
no everything else about human morality
is wrong and oppressive and stigmatizing
blah blah blah and everything about this
is just perfectly good it's just their
bigots it's a way easier thing to do
than that all right so you just gave me
the perfect segue to bring up something
that I have never talked about on this
show and in some ways I don't really
want to talk about but having you here I
kind of feel like I have to talk about
it which is an old colleague of mine at
The Young Turks anakasparian who has
said some really really unbelievable
horrible dishonest things about me it's
not important actually I'm not going to
repeat any of them um the internet sort
of knows what they are is what it is but
we were extremely good friends invited
to my wedding etc etc but apparently and
I only know this from some of the videos
that you've done uh she's having some
sort of wakeup she's waking up out of
this leftism and this sort of mental
prison that you're describing um you
think you can get her over the
edge I don't want to try um
because she's been very embedded very
publicly in what I would call radical
leftwing morality for a very long time
and Sul niton has this uh particular
quote that probably everyone knows where
the the the a lot of the time these
people even when reality is hitting them
in the face with the consequence of
their own ideology they won't admit it
well actually uh Anna is being hit in
the face with the quences of this
morality and it's going okay I was wrong
um cuz she I think she got assaulted by
a homeless person outside of her house
uh I think that she's very aware that uh
the the trans Lobby have got to the
point where they're going to degrade her
status as woman to merely birthing
person or something like that and she's
and you know I'm sure she pays way too
much in taxes to Gavin new which I hear
she's not a fan of his policies and so
she's got to the point where now it's
affecting her and it's like hang on a
second actually we need to arrest
criminals actually giving half my wages
to the state is not moral is not moral
is isn't making the world a better place
actually a lot of the things the left
are saying such as uh there is no
difference between men and women uh
these are not truths right and you can't
really build morality on untruths
actually and so I think that she's come
to the point where it's untenable for
her you know I think I think that Jen is
still essentially wedded to the left and
leftwing morality and so I think he's
afraid afid of going of looking the
reflection in the mirror and saying look
this is actually kind of hideous it's
kind of maybe maybe the sort of Dorian
Gray painting might be a better thing
right going and looking at the painting
and looking at the rot on the face of
the painting and being like Oh my God is
that secretly me in my heart you know
and so I I'm actually tremendously
sympathetic right and I realize that
that's not probably what you would like
to hear because she was well you she's
been unbelievably nasty and dishonest to
me but I but I in a weird way I am
because I'm sympathetic to people that
are waking up to the truth and I would
want someone to get to the end of the
road and you know we could still have
some disagreements about this that or
the other thing and I'm not expecting
nor uh request an apology um but it
would be nice to see someone that has
some influence waking up to truth like
that's pretty good A a part of me feels
that she's kind of the victim of the
ideology and I'm not trying to say that
she's got no agency or anything like
that but well she used to say but way
back when that you know when she got
there at The Young Turks she knew
nothing about politics and Jen
everything right and so congratulations
and if you're you know you're a host on
a massive Channel you've got thousands
and thousands of people every day either
reinforcing what you your biases are
that you've been taught or castigating
you for having an independent thought of
your own you can see how someone would
be like well I'll just move away from
that and into the safe place where I'm
allowed to say leftwing things
and I there's a part of me that I mean
it was it Jordan Pon who called it the
Mind virus
well now it's sort of everybody saying
it but I think Gad sad May said it
originally corre the parasitic mind was
one of his exactly sorry Gad
um he's I think he's right to call it a
mind virus and I think that one when you
have a kind of disease it's not
necessarily your fault if you are in ill
temper basically um and so there's a
part of me that is that doesn't see her
necessarily as being the author of the
actions she was kind of operating in a
pre-planned way if someone is an
apostate from leftism that's worse than
being a heretic you know that it's it's
always worse to be the apostate and so
it's predictable that she would act that
way and one would hope now that with her
having a kind of damine moment of her
own being like hang on a second these
people are evil and wrong and them cruel
they're being cruel to me maybe she'll
think well in a way I was cruel to
people I loved actually and
maybe I owe them an apology was the most
shocking part to you as you were talking
about this stuff and and sort of seeing
the hate from you know your side so to
speak what I was more amazed by yes I
was shocked by the hate and I ended up
developing an autoimmune disease because
of it and lost like 40% of my hair I
mean I could not believe how much hate I
was getting from the supposed good guys
so I'm not saying that was nothing but
the thing that actually shocked me more
so and even to this day still shocks me
in a weird way is how conservatives who
I still might disagree with on some of
the social issues I'm begrudgingly pro-
Choice I'm married to a man as I said
like there might be some stuff there
that my life is not traditionally
conservative obviously I get nothing but
love from them nothing but love and I am
invited to religious things of various
denominations all the time um and I find
them acting far more liberally if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop screaming check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell